[Music]
hello this is an interview with the
authors of the paper on memory assisted
prompt editing to improve gpt3 after
deployment if you haven't seen it i've
made a comprehensive paper review on
this paper and i released that yesterday
so the authors that i'm having on today
as guests have seen that paper and we're
able to dive right in so if you haven't
seen it might be a good place to check
it out i wish that you have a lot of fun
following this interview or that you
learned something or that you're
entertained ideally all three together
and yeah have fun bye-bye
everyone today i'm here with aman madan
and niket tandon of the paper memory
assisted prompt editing to improve gpt3
after deployment amon and nikit thank
you very much for being here welcome
thank you for inviting me
so you've set out to to write this paper
and i guess the viewers have probably
seen the review um
and this is really cool because these
large language models sure we now have a
fine-tuning endpoint at gpt3 so it is a
little bit possible to adjust it to your
use case but i think what you're doing
right here comes the closest to what
people imagine when they hear ai like
when someone when when i go to someone
and sell them and artificially like an
ai system they imagine a computer
program that learns immediately right
that they can they can like tell things
too and it adapts you know it gets
smarter as they interact with it and
largely the ai community has not
delivered on that promise we train
things on static data sets and then we
deploy them and they're frozen uh yeah
your system i think yeah it comes the
closest to really to live up to that
promise so i think that's that's really
cool how did you how did you go like how
did this come to be how did you figure
you know let's
let's build something let's build a
plug-in for gpt3 our original motivation
was can we personalize very large models
such as jpd3 rather than having many
copies of
a giant gpd3 model trained in one place
on one static data along the way with
the user the models can improve
personalize over time this was the
original motivation why we started with
this part and gpt3 was a great example
to start with because it is such a large
model that at the time of writing it was
not possible to fine-tune these models
yeah so i think similar to that one of
the reasons why you know we specifically
thought of having a plug-in of software
g3s
so i was using copilot for some time and
co-pilot makes this same mistake every
time i write a print statement
so i am using
something like python 3.7 which has f
strings this is a way of displaying the
output which you can nicely splice
strings with variables
but the co-pilot could always use the
older version of print statements
and i would have to go back edit it and
you know make it the string that i want
so it was natural to you know kind of
there was this urge you know i wish
there was something that would uh
personalize this uh id to me but this
instance of codex to me and you know
something like a hashmap would work in
that case so whenever gpd3 completes it
with an older print statement i can just
have a regex that replaces it with an
string
and that kind of motivated this whole
idea of having a small plug-in
outside of gpd3 that stores these error
cases and can
correct them on the fly
uh and you know in the first version we
like you know we had some sort of proof
of concept with uh
the idea is to kind of not having to
frame the model and having something
super light that can adjust to these
things that more people repeatedly
yeah it's cool and you don't even need
to be open ai to do this right because
most most research sort of assumes
you're in control of the model but this
is really something you you can just
hang in front of whatever model that
you're consuming which is which is
pretty cool so i think you know
it is important to say that i was quite
critical of the paper in some places and
is good to inform the viewers that there
is actually a v2 out that addresses i
think almost all of these criticisms in
in one batch so i just quickly want to i
want to show that and you told me that
it got done like just in time last night
or so
so there is a new new version of the
paper uh which is on github right now i
guess that's also coming on archive uh
in the in the near future and that does
have a lot more experiments because i
think one of the issues i had is that
you said well we just want to present
the framework of things
and um
you did some experiments but can you
maybe uh
you know just talk about what new
experiments you've added and how those
turned out in this in this new version
because if you know with new experiments
and being state of the art it is it sort
of invalidates my point of well you just
present only a framework
yeah so
we did add like two different themes
of tasks one is ethical reasoning
and the other is more word reasoning in
ethical reasoning this is a recent topic
on ethical ai which is as an example if
i have turn on the blender at 3am i ask
the system is this ethically correct to
do or not
and the system will probably should
probably say that it is not okay to turn
on your blender at 3am because it might
disturb your neighbors that's one theme
which is ethical ethical ai and
we have two different tasks within that
uh in one case the input is you know a
string like i said turn on the blender
at 3 am like a situation and the output
is whether it is good bad or not and
like with some clarification or some
understanding sorry not clarification
just understanding of the model
why it believes this is the case and we
have two different types of
understanding in it
that makes up the two you know two
different tasks one is it
clarify it the model
presents its understanding based on
an explanation of the sort that
it's not good to wake up your neighbors
or disturb your neighbors at in the in
the night that's one
and the other setup we have which makes
up a different task is you know it's it
says this is about care or harm this is
about you know the topic what
this situation is uh intended to bring
out
so that's one task one theme of task the
other one is more
word reasoning tasks so
we add on to the synthetic
lexical
relation task that we had in this or in
the v1 paper and we add on to word
scrambling and other tasks
which are involving you know
anagrams
and
how to
uh fill up how to
correct a word misspelled and so on so
those are like two different themes of
tasks we have
amanda you want to say something on the
second task
so i think we also added one other task
which is factual push answering so
suppose that user wants to ask factual
questions like
who is
or where was a
certain person born or ready to go to
school
so things like that so in those cases
there is no understanding that the model
can display
of the instruction other than the answer
itself
so for example if you ask where did
albert extend goes to
if the model says stanford uh then you
can correct the model and say no of etf
zurich or something
and then
you can store these corrections in the
memory again and then when you create
the prompt you would bring in some
examples which are similar to the
question on which the model has been
wrong before
uh to make the call so for example if a
question comes in where it means
instructional goals
then you would already have an example
in memory
of the albert einstein example and that
would that we show is helping
uh the model getting better at least so
two different things
have you so
um yeah so this this it's pretty cool
and i've i've had a flick through this
paper uh that it the tasks seem to be
much more extensive nah that's not it
it's uh
so you had the ethical one you give a
few examples right here yeah on the
right we can see um for example the
understanding this question is about
loving your partner this question about
seeking medical attention if you feel
there's something wrong
which is
a lot i think
you know the
the gap to what what people usually call
common sense get smaller and smaller
have you
let any
users any actual users use this system
uh with gpt3 so you came up with your
own data set as if i understand
correctly your own sort of feedbacks
sometimes heuristics and so on did you
ever just
you know set this in front of someone
and say you know here you go try it out
um
no we have not that's uh one of the
things we would like to do so we have
not done that yet and in fact in
just to clarify
the
the data sets that we have here are
the feedbacks on ethical reasoning for
example
is not something that we came up with
this was present in the data itself so
this was a data which was crowdsourced
through uh
mechanical turk and there were actual
users who
um or actual mechanical workers who gave
this feedback
but on the other hand we have not tried
this on any real users this is the
closest we came to reality in some sense
but we would like to do this in the
future
yeah yeah um it it'd be super cool to to
see how real people interact with this
sorry aman
yeah so i think so like nikki said that
for both these data sets uh the data set
is real so you write in the first
version we had one of the data sets that
we collected ourselves but in this case
the feedback is given by humans so in
since in some sense we are approximating
that process by a linear
data collection process as opposed to a
bunch of characters working on it at the
same time
but yes it it would be great to kind of
see you know once deployed this actually
does better on
uh one of these tasks or one of the new
tasks that we discussed
i'm going to guess that specifically for
gpt-3 the uh the restriction of openai
on what you can build with it and the
approval process would prevent you from
actually releasing this let's say to the
public as a as a service
but one could think of maybe using
another model or just um i mean your
code is online so people could use it
with their own api key if they really
wanted to
yeah that is correct and and in fact
just outside of this paper also we had
been working on t5 model with a very
similar architecture t511b and so that's
one of the models we could you know
release in the future is there is there
a
difference between smaller models and
larger models in how much this type of
feedback is needed like you specifically
work with gpt3 and you know i get it
that's the model that we cannot train
but is it also more necessary to provide
feedback can you tell us a little bit
about the differences between small and
large models or different models
let me just start with that so it's a
really good question first of all
so our general experience with injecting
you know some knowledge external
knowledge like you know common sense
knowledge into models has been as
the model capacity keeps increasing it
requires comparatively less
knowledge injection so smaller models
like you know
let's say bard base would require
would benefit a lot by we have seen this
in the experiments in the past on on and
others have also reported it
if you inject external common sense
knowledge then those models
uh get much bigger boost than for
example t511b
bigger models get less boost so
we
we have tried the same very similar
architecture actually almost the same
architecture there's a paper under
review
on
t5 11b and what we also observe there is
that there is substantial gains with
d511p the only different in mechanism is
that you know
there we were able to fine tune have a
fine tuned t5 model which which
understands the task a lot better than
in gpd3 where there was not even an
opportunity to do that so
probably because of that reason we are
seeing bigger boost in gpt3 than we did
with t511p but in both the cases there
is substantial boost uh in performance
by doing so
cool and have you tried so what you are
doing right here it goes very much into
the direction of correcting the model if
it let's say makes a mistake uh or if
you misunderstand something i've i've
i had the uh sort of the opinion that
personalization very much in the sense
of how you amon said this before you
know i i want my ide to do something in
a particular way uh would benefit hugely
from that is this something on on your
mind too are you looking into various
like personalization aspects of these
models is or or am i or is is this
something that is for some reason not
possible
yeah i think that's a very good point
and
in fact in the first version in in this
version we have some experiments on the
appendix also in the earlier version
where we uh simulate users who
sort of interact with the model in hindi
or punjabi
and that's some sort of personalization
it's kind of a language personalization
so there's a person who's speaking in a
timely of uh hindi or punjabi and you
know there's a certain phrase they use
repeatedly
and if you can store that in memory then
sure the first time the model is not
negligated but the next time someone
comes and uses the same word
uh you know hopefully
it will be patched
uh so
we are we did kind of did some
experiments uh on that angle uh and we
also have examples in the ethical ai
setting where
the model was able to correct or
kind of
work with slang usage
um
when people were saying the same thing
in slangs right so
one person comes and takes feedback so i
think it's a it's a very promising
direction for personalization and i i
anticipate that
you know in the near future systems that
do successfully
use a similar architecture where they
have this memory
that kind of hazard
[Music]
um if we get into the paper a little bit
like in into a bit more sort of the the
technical aspects here i want to jump
over to the experiment section and you
had an interesting uh plot where you
show not this one not this one this one
is one of them an interesting no this is
the outer vocabulary i think the main
ones are
i miss them oh here i've drawn so much
over them that it's
it's a mess
um
specifically i i was i was wondering
this
pfb of 0.5 did i interpret this
correctly that this means that you only
get the feedback half of the time
does that mean the user can only give
feedback half of the time or the model
only receives sort of this feedback or
the model only gets to go through this
feedback loop half of the time
uh the user gives feedback
okay because then and then they grow
slowly
then it makes total sense that they end
up sort of converging to the same place
because i was wondering you know if if
your procedure was only active half the
time
it should fail half the time but if the
user is able to give feedback half the
time it would still learn it slowly but
it would still learn over time okay
that's
we wanted to simulate reluctant users
who might you know not always give
feedback so yeah sometimes you want to
give feedback sometimes smart yeah
have you have you thought about pairing
this with recommender systems because in
recommender system uh sort of a
recommender system would group me
together with other users who have like
similar preferences as i do so you know
conceivably i could say well
maybe
i'm able to sort of profit off of
feedback of those users right if i
if i give some feedback and i'm very
similar to these users
it might be the same is this something
that that could be done or
yeah
i think this is a really neat idea we
did not think about it but now that i
think about it when you mentioned it i
think it is a
it makes total sense to have a community
of similar users all having you know
similar preferences
it makes total sense and i think it will
be very cool to try this in the future
well maybe or you always know who the
feedback comes from is like ah your dumb
friend
entered
yeah i think i'm thinking of these
people uh who who enter who like all
together enter dumb things into google
so that google autocomplete suggests the
dumb thing
you know that brings to a very good
point about um
sabotaging our system
it is possible i mean if you keep giving
it really bad feedback eventually it is
going to apply bad feedback to
uh you know
newer examples and the this is a valid
point a valid concern
we also don't know if our memory can be
consistent over time or can start
deteriorating and becoming like
inconsistent among itself you know i i
could just give different examples with
different feedbacks so there is
not not our work but there has been
other work on you know how to maintain
consistency in a memory over time
but that that's an additional uh
direction of research which we can
employ within our system to keep it
healthy and uh consistent
are there
you another in another point in the
paper you mention these different
pieces of the puzzle in in this
framework you you propose um you've
added more tasks have you also thought
about um
amending or augmenting some of these
things to be more let's say more
complicated maybe replace some stuff
with learn things so far you have the
lookup which is a a language model or an
embedding model
yet the other pieces of the puzzle here
are fairly simple so far in your
experiments are there any
obvious next steps uh where to make this
more powerful in any of these four parts
um
yeah so
that is true in fact the current
implementation is um for the combiner is
as simple as you know it's just a
threshold it's just thresholding over
the inner product you know it's that
simple
but eventually
we are in the process so this is very
much work in progress where we are
trying to you know beef up the other
components also right now our only focus
was on lookup and memory and the other
components are very simple
but eventually this is where we are
getting at
you know work work in progress and i
think there are lots of lots of details
where you know our current system is
very prim primitive in the sense that
it um
it only assumes that the users are you
know really nice and
uh
that they don't
give you bad feedback that's one it also
assumes that
the users can
you know you can effectively retrieve
from the past and that's not always the
case you know we there are cases where
we are not able to do that that's why we
have to set you know a higher threshold
where we
we
only get
good
good matches and like good feedback
which are very similar
but you know something which we would
like to do in lookup i'm just giving an
example is like suppose your input is
turn on the blender at 3 am
and
now a new input comes in which is saying
playing drums late night you know both
of them are in the analogy space of
errors they're actually very similar but
that's not something which our current
system can match it can at most say oh
well if if i find something like turn on
the mixer at 2 am that's similar to
something i've found and it'll pick that
feedback you know so this kind of
really recursive reminding
to a model based on
similar error space
is the next step where we are getting to
with this lookup
i think also in the space of
the combiner and the prompter
specifically there's probably a lot of
potential to still be gained i mean
instead of concatenating you could you
can imagine any
you know many smart ways of combining
what you retrieve from the memory with
what you already have but potentially
you could even ask the model itself to
come up with sort of like a better
prompt or
to to sort of so you can you can maybe
abuse the model again to suggest better
things to you i mean i i think that the
possibilities are are quite quite open
here to make this very very cool very
powerful
um
another thing that i wasn't sure about
is your baseline this grow prompt
baseline right here and i think i tried
to explain this a little bit
do i understand correctly that
the grow prompt baseline you take
whatever the contents of your memory are
and you just append them to the prompt
before the question
that's good
okay
um yeah my concern was a little bit that
it's not exactly right that the baseline
because the prompt is structured
differently but i don't know how
important that ultimately will be
probably not
so i i think we do structure the problem
in the same fashion so we get examples
and
the structure of the problem does not
change it's just like a longer problem
so in the video you show an example from
uh which is in the appendix it's the
same format it's just much longer it's
basically as much as we can flip
yeah so wait we can i mean we can look
at we can look at one here
so there this is the entire prompt which
i found pretty cool that not only do you
prime the model to sort of give you the
answers and give you the understanding
which is you know
that's i think that's pretty cool idea
in itself to get side information with
your main information out of these
models that you can then use to query
them again i think the applications for
this are much larger than just this one
you also train the model to specifically
view or regard or pay attention to the
clarifications
my question was that
let's let's
this is a bit fat um
when in your main method when you
retrieve a clarification do i see this
correctly that you append it at the end
right here to the to the question
currently and this
this grow sort of this baseline would
append something like here
in between
or do i see this incorrectly
right so in the grow prompt what we do
is uh we essentially add more examples
to the prompt so instead of retrieving
something from the memory it's added to
the prompt itself yeah
yeah okay so that's cool yeah
then i've understood correctly
mechanism is kind of very similar
uh to our own method sort of like uh you
know retrieve the right feedback in some
sense the only thing is we now we are
allowing gpt3 to attend over those
uh
to attend over it rather than you know
be providing a retrieval function from
the memory
we hope that gpd3 will be able to attend
over it itself yes i mean yeah and if it
fits into the prompt it's it's pretty
pretty certain that at least it might
pick up on it right and you make good
points here you say that these the
scroll prompt it is quite a bit larger
and it cannot scale up
so as soon as things fall out of your
memory without a good retrieval function
you're essentially limited to a very
short time horizon
there is this
experiment here this plot right here
which i haven't touched at all which it
goes a little bit into out of vocabulary
domain a little bit into the domain of
different languages maybe lower resource
languages do you want to comment a
little bit on what you what you did
there and what your findings were
yeah so the idea is essentially
very similar to what i was talking about
earlier so the prompt itself
has examples from hindi for example
and then the questions also come again
and you know for the first time the
question comes gp3 would not know
because it's primarily english funny
thing is for him he actually sometimes
it gets it or apparently there's lots of
you know
english
english purpose online but for punjabi
it struggles
so the idea is the user comes in enters
something the model doesn't get it it
goes in the memory next time something
comes
has a similar question so the model
retrieves understanding from the memory
and
hopefully is able to do the task
so to to clarify that the
the questions are in punjabi for example
that you would like to have answered and
you also construct a prompt in punjabi
or is the prompt still in english
the prompt is transcribed in english but
the quotient parts are all in punjabi so
the script is not the
you know
the
javascript it's still english but parts
of it are in punjabi
so we have an example in the appendix
yeah oh yeah that's a good point
[Laughter]
we should we should go
um
it's uh
yeah
no
this yeah so i think one of those um
[Music]
this is the end right here i think this
one might be yeah yeah so so those are
in hindi and okay the one in the bottom
is in the 30 so the person is you know
trying to the the scenario i had in mind
or someone's trying to learn english and
they're trying to you know look up words
so in the first case they are saying
what is the
opposite of edit
uh so they say they ask it in punjabi so
they know that they want meaning of this
word edit
and the rest of it they ask in punjabi
and the model says something
that the opposite of this is something
else and then the person can say you
know i
i want synonyms
and there's like one missing piece here
which is that you have to tell the user
antenna means opposite in pajamas so
they know what the model is uh
you know it's trying to say
but okay so you could interact with this
thing sort of across languages and you
could prime it uh to say
which parts do i want in which language
because it would obviously not know i
guess
what what you want the answer in
yeah
yeah you can definitely add language
tags and that fact
i mean it's a pretty cool example of
exactly of personalization right because
you can imagine you you personalize this
exactly to
sort of how you want to interact with it
and someone else who might be more or
less skilled at english or or in in
reverse in punjabi might do a different
thing that's pretty cool
yeah
there's one more point i wanted to touch
here which you kind of mentioned earlier
with respect to the problem so
as you noticed in in our in our prompt
the model does not only give out the
answer it also gives out its
understanding of the question
and i think that's a very kind of
crucial piece in this design because one
of the bottlenecks for us earlier was
this system a system that assumed that
the user knows the real answer
is not really practical because if the
user
if a user knew the answer why would they
be playing with the model right outside
of a annotation setting
so this kind of breaks that barrier so
you might not know what the answer is
but you know for sure what you ask for
so you can always tell the model no this
is not i don't know if you're right but
i know for sure this is not what i
wanted
and that kind of helps in
improving the performance
the performance of the model itself
might be
whatever it is but we are helping the
model in understanding that maintain
more precisely
that's the i guess the main trick here
yeah i like this just getting the answer
with the understanding i think that's
that's pretty powerful uh not only yeah
to interact with the model but also just
to understand what it does instead of
just getting a sim simple answer
could be a good recipe for other
applications as well did you have to
fiddle around a lot with sort of the
prompt structure or the structure of
what to add right now you have you have
a bar and then clarification and then
colon uh is this the first try and it
worked or is this the result of many
hours of uh sweat and tears
no so it's a first try and we did not uh
and it was intentional because our goal
was not to show our game
it works and you know this weird hash
and new line
this is what we took from openair's
website they had a bunch of instructions
on best practices for formatting your
prompt
i think they have changed itself but we
just took it from openly
yeah and this was also one of the main
motivations like you know even if i
don't know how to exactly have the
prompts here let me
uh you know there are two ways in which
you could
gain improvements here one is in the in
context examples within the prompt and
the other is at the question side you
know there are like just two aspects to
um
for fiddling with with this and there's
been a lot of work on you know how to
give the write in context examples what
order what examples how to select them
our focus is on the question part like
you know only on the input part with the
which comes from the user and we are
trying to pull all the knobs like turn
all the knobs at that end and in some
sense we were able to overcome you know
some limitations which
uh
which our prompts probably have like
maybe there are much better ways of of
coming up with the problem than we have
but i think all those methods are just
if we plug in any of the nicer methods
to uh you know come up with a better
prompt that's just icing on the cake for
us
could you
if this was first try and it's still in
there so obviously it worked was there
things that didn't work out over the
course of this research like things
where you got stuck or maybe even ideas
that you had to discard halfway through
um i can tell one which uh which really
bothered us for a long time it's on
contrastive prompting which is we wanted
to also give like negative answers like
can the user just say you know no i
that's not the right answer you know if
with with the auto regressive models uh
it is
really difficult to
somehow give them
steer away from from you know
probability mass towards certain tokens
like it's really difficult to do that we
are still not able to effectively do
that like ideally you know in the real
world users will give i think users will
give feedback of the kind you know
instead of clarifications in addition to
clarification they can also say no this
is not right or this is why it's not
right like the model came up with what's
the capital of
india and it says the capital is mumbai
and i just want to say no it is not it
is it is like delhi like you're looking
at the wrong places and
that's something which we were not able
to do and i think it's an open problem
like this kind of negative prompting
it's valuable from a feedback
perspective for the future
we just don't know how to solve it right
now
is your
maybe what did you
you played obviously a little bit with
these large models uh with the api
presumably also tried out yourself a lot
of things i can only assume over the
course of this research is there
anything
maybe also a bit independent of the
research itself is there anything that
you came across that surprised you about
these large models and how how people
can interact with them
i think for me one of the things that
i've actually stood out from early days
is how good co-value goes
and
i think if you really have been using it
on a day-to-day basis and i have been
using it for a few months now
it has consistently gotten better and
initially it had these small weird
quarks so you know these models can
basically generate left to right or top
to bottom
so if i have some but when you program
you would write some functions below and
then you go back up to a function and
you want to reference the function below
um so that did not work earlier so you
know you would it would only condition
on things that it had seen so far in the
file
but they have improved over that stuff
uh also so i think it's um
it's astonishing that at least in the
structure setting how good they are for
generating things
at the same time it's also interesting
that even when you have 175 billion
parameters how good the model is at
common sense because uh you know it's
very clear
when you go from these structured
settings to a more open-ended setting
like common sense generation or
concentration
i still think the models struggle a lot
so it still is clear that you know
there's a long way to go
uh there's a bit of you know both i
think you have to choose your
end application uh wisely
but there are clearly very cool
applications that can be built you know
for which you don't need agi
as long as you're a very good patent
manager
one of the surprises for me was on
like just
the fact that these models are
correctable you know like
a model can make mistakes which which
are hopeless you know it's just
total understanding is wrong but i think
over time what has happened is with
larger models
even though there might be many claims
that
it is missing common sense and it is um
you know these models are dumb and so on
but i i do
i do believe that you know for a certain
question yes there might be there might
be cases where it's not coming up with
the right answer but they're still
correctable they're not dumb anymore i
think these models are getting
they're correctable in the sense that
their output is not completely off and
with some guidance they can get to the
right answer
awesome um is there something other than
that that you feel i have maybe not
touched in my review that you would like
viewers to know or
you know be able to to understand or
anything that i've maybe gotten wrong
um
yeah i think most of the stuff you said
was correct like it was nothing was
wrong really
um
yeah your understanding and almost
everything was was correct just the only
thing i'm not i'm not fishing for
compliments
legitimately if there's something that
you you feel like you know people should
know about this that we haven't talked
about at all um yeah
yeah
i think the part about that you
mentioned in your video about uh the
feedback would be misleading i think
we'd be best upon it but i think that's
a valid criticism that still holds and
that was one of the things that we have
not been able to solve even now
so we have we are trying you know
different kinds of retrieval
uh
conditioning on the expected output
doing something like you said more
more complex
in one of those four modules but i think
that remains a valid criticism of the
work that there would be cases where
a feedback would distract so the model
was going to say the right thing but now
because you have this thing it's saying
the wrong thing
uh but we think that problem is kind of
uh there's an easy way to solve it it's
to show both the answers to the user and
let the user pick one so you know you
show this is the answer that i would
have given you this is what i will give
you with symmetry feedback pick one
but if you don't want to do that then
it's kind of
very challenging because
the model somehow has to know
that it's going to make a mistake
uh and only then it's pictured full of
feedback etcetera and those are kind of
you know having
um it's very hard for
models to know that they are wrong or to
know what they don't know so that's a
big challenge and a kind of one
interesting research direction that we
are pursuing outside of this which is
how can we let a model know that they
don't know
uh or they started
going wrong and
i agree and if you can if you can do
that with a model that you don't even
have access to i think that would be a
little bit of a a little bit of a grail
of research
like that would be seriously cool um and
it i think it would it would improve a
lot of applications of these models
around
uh you know all around technology
cool well uh nikket and aman thank you
very much for being here was a pleasure
and i hope this work goes on and becomes
it becomes more powerful over time
thanks annik thank you thank you so much
for having us
[Music]
you